♪ ♪
>> Greg: ANOTHER NIGHT OF
LOOTING, AND WHAT IS THE MEDIA’S
PRIORITY?
>> HE CALLS THEM THUGS, WHO IS
THE THUG HERE?
HIDING IN A BUNKER?
HIDING BEHIND A SUIT?
>> WE ARE TEETERING ON A
DICTATORSHIP?
>> IS THE PRESIDENT DECLARING
WAR?
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT HAD BEEN
SAYING INCENDIARY THINGS,
CERTAINLY IF YOU HAD BEEN
LISTENING WITH ANY KIND OF
OPEN-MINDEDNESS, CERTAINLY NOT
HELPFUL THINGS.
>> ALL ABOUT CALLING ON
AUTHORITIES TO CRACK’S GOALS AND
THE PROTEST, IT’S NOT SOMETHING
YOU SEE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, IT’S SOMETHING YOU SEE
IN AN AUTHORITARIAN COUNTRY.
>> Greg: AMAZING.
MEANWHILE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HEADLINE READS AMERICA’S PROTEST
WON’T STOP UNTIL POLICE
BRUTALITY DOES.
MEANING THAT THIS COULD GO ON
FOREVER.
ONE OF THEIR SCRIBES CHIDES
MAYOR de BLASIO FOR BEING TOO
PRO-POLICE.
MEANWHILE THE CITY EARNS AND
STORES ARE ALLUDED, COPS ARE
BEATEN, AND PEOPLE ARE BEATEN
TOO.
AT THE NEW YORK MEDIA BY
STICKING TO THEIR NARRATIVE THAT
WE DESERVE THE PUNISHMENT REJECT
PROTECTING THE CITIZENS, AND
MOCK THE NEED FOR MILITARY
INTERVENTION.
WE HAVE SPOUSES WHO WORK AT
NIGHT, WHEN THE LEADERS BELIEVE
THE MAYHEM IS INEVITABLE AND
PERHAPS NECESSARY, TO PROTECT US
NOW.
STILL PEOPLE BLAME TRUMP.
I WATCH THE STREETS OF MY HOME
DESTROYED.
IT WAS NOT TRUMP, IT WAS
CRIMINALS THAT KNEW THAT THE
LIGHT TOUCH OF IMPORTANT LEADERS
CALLS FOR RUIN.
HOW IS IT TRUMP’S FAULT THAT AID
COP KILLED A DEFENSE THIS MAN
AND A LIBERAL TOWN.
HELD BY LIBERAL POLITICIANS.
IT’S NOT.
IT’S WILD WHEN YOU SAY EVERYBODY
IS IN AGREEMENT OVER MR. FLOYD
INCLUDING TRUMP, THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
WHICH TELLS YOU THAT THEY WANT
NO END TO THE VIOLENCE.
THEY WANT TO BURN IT ALL DOWN.
THEY THE RADICALS IN THE STREET
IN FACULTY LOUNGES IN THE
GOVERNMENT COMING IN THE
MINORITY KEEPERS ARE PLAYING
DUMB AT PAYING THE PRICE THAT
THE MINORITY OWNERS OF
RESTAURANTS ARE PAYING THE
PRICE.
MINORITY IS ALWAYS PAID THE
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
PAYING THE PRICE ARE THE MEDIA.
THEY WAX POETIC AND THEY BREAK
IT IN, THEY HOPE IF THEY FEED
THE CROCODILE ENOUGH AS
CHURCHILL ONCE SAID, IT WILL EAT
THEM LAST, IT WILL, AND THEN IT
WILL GET FOOD POISONING.
>> Greg: SO DANA, I CAN’T
HONESTLY EVEN FOCUS ANYMORE ON
THIS.
THEY WERE THROWING HAMMERS AT MY
RESIDENTIAL WINDOWS BECAUSE THEY
CAN’T STEAL ANYTHING ANYMORE.
AND YET WE HAVE -- WE HAVE
LEADERS WHO ARE MORE UPSET, THE
MEDIA IS MORE UPSET ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TWEETS THAN
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
BEATEN.
I DON’T GET IT.
>> Dana: THE MEDIA AND ALSO
WAYS IN SELECTING THE LOCAL AND
STATE OFFICIALS IN SOME PLACES.
FOR EXAMPLE IN NEW YORK IT IS
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT THEY SEEM
TO BE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LAWLESS THEN FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY OBEY THE LAW.
THE TAXPAYERS.
I THINK OF ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
WORKED REALLY HARD AND TRY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING, THAT’S THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE.
THEN THEY DID THE LOCKDOWN, THEY
LOST THEIR BUSINESSES, THEY LOST
THEIR LIVELIHOODS, PROBABLY MANY
LOST THEIR SAVINGS AND THEIR
HOPE IN THEIR DREAMS, AND IT
IS -- I’M SORRY THAT YOU ARE
DEPRESSED, BECAUSE IT IS HARD
FOR EVERYBODY WHO IS A FAN OF
YOURS, GREG, TO SEE YOU LIKE
THIS, BUT WE KNOW THAT IT IS
FROM THE HEART AND YOU ARE
WITNESSING SOMETHING THAT FEELS
LIKE THE CITY IN THE NATION IS
FIGHTING FOR ITS LIFE, AND WE
NEED HELP IN ORDER TO WIN THIS
FIGHT, I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
AND WE WILL COME OUT STRONGER, I
ALSO -- IF I CAN JUST MENTION
TWO THINGS, ONE, THE NOTION THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS HIDING IN THE
BUNKER, I JUST WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR, NO PRESIDENT ASKS TO GO
DOWN TO THE BUNKER.
THAT IS A SECRET SERVICE
DECISION, THEY COME AND THEY
TELL YOU, SIR, YOU ARE GOING TO
THE BUNKER.
THEY ACTUALLY HAD TO CARRY
DICK CHENEY TO THE BUNKER,
BECAUSE HE DID NOT WANT TO GO
AFTER 9/11.
SO I HOPE THAT THE MEDIA UP
SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
HIDING.
THAT WAS NOT HIS CHOICE.
THE SECRET SERVICE IS IN CHARGE,
AND THE OTHER THING THAT THE
MEDIA MENTIONS, MICHELLE
GOLDBERG CALLING US AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," AND I READ
HER BECAUSE I LIKE THE
PERSPECTIVE, AND THE HEADLINE IS
THAT SHE THINKS de BLASIO
SHOULD RESIGN, LEFT, LEFT-WING
COLUMNIST, AND I THOUGHT WE ARE
ON THE SAME PAGE, AND THEN I
REALIZED, OH, NO, SHE WANTS HIM
TO RESIGN BECAUSE HE IS NOT
PROGRESSIVE ENOUGH, BECAUSE HE
IS CITED TOO OFTEN WITH THE
POLICE.
IF YOU SAW ON THE DAILY
BRIEFING, ONE OF THE POLICE
OFFICERS WHO WENT AFTER
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAYING YOU HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT IT IS LIKE TO BE
US, WE DO NOT FEEL SUPPORTED BY
THE LUGER LEADERSHIP.
I WILL LEAVE IT THERE.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW, YOU ARE IN
D.C. DURING 9/11, MAYBE YOU WERE
IN NEW YORK, I WAS IN NEW YORK,
AND IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS SO
MUCH WORSE BECAUSE IT IS DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF CITIES AND US
VERSUS THE TERRORISTS, BUT NOW
THAT TERRORISTS ARE US AND WE
CAN’T DO ANYTHING, BECAUSE THEY
HAVE HIJACKED A MOVEMENT, AND
THEY CAN EXPEL THEM, THAT’S WHY
WE ARE EATING OURSELVES ALIVE,
AND WHILE THE POLITICIANS ARE SO
FLACCID ON THIS >> Juan: THAT’S
INTERESTING PERSPECTIVE, WE LOST
A LOT OF LIVES IN 9/11 SO FAR,
THINK OUT IN TERMS OF THE
PROTEST HERE, IT HAS BEEN
NOTHING COMPARABLE TO IT BUT I
WANTED TO JOIN WITH YOU IN
SAYING I WANT TO UNEQUIVOCALLY
CONDEMN THE VIOLENCE.
I THINK IT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
EVEN FOR THOSE OF US WHO ARE
SEEKING SOME KIND OF POSITIVE
SOCIAL CHANGE IN TERMS OF
RECKONING AND CALLING FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY IN POLICE
BRUTALITY.
TO DR. KING, SO MANY OTHERS HAVE
SPOKEN OUT ABOUT HOW THAT KIND
OF VIOLENCE DOES WHAT YOU SAID.
IT ALLOWS CRITICS HIJACK VIRTUAL
MOVEMENT AND DERAIL IT, BECAUSE
HE CAN’T BUILD COALITIONS ON
THAT BASIS.
AT THE SAME TIME, GREG.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
ARE PENALTIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
BREAK THE LAW AS PROTESTERS, AND
PEOPLE BREAK THE LAW IN TERMS OF
BRUTAL TACTICS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
ARE EQUAL TREATMENTS ALL THE WAY
AROUND.
BECAUSE TO ME WE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY SYSTEMIC RACISM, AND I
KNOW THAT PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO
DEAL WITH IT OR ACKNOWLEDGE IT,
THEY WANT TO GET BACK TO NORMAL
AND SAY, HOW CAN WE DEAL WITH
THAT, HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE TO
CORRECT, BUT WE NEED TO DO IT.
WE CAN BOTH AGREE THAT IT IS
HARDER TO BE A BLACK MAN IN
AMERICA THEN IT IS TO BE A WHITE
MAN IN AMERICA, AND WE NEED TO
CONFRONT THIS, BECAUSE IT IS
CONTRARY TO OUR IDEALS ABOUT
EQUALITY.
>> Greg: IT DEPENDS WHAT BLACK
MAN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT, BUT I
AGREE THAT THERE IS RACISM.
TO THE PROBLEM IS, AND LIKE YOU
SAID, WE ALL AGREE ON IT, IT
DOES NOT STOP THE VIOLENCE.
IT IS LIKE, OKAY, WE WANT TO
HELP YOU, WHAT CAN WE DO?
AND THEN THE VIOLENCE STILL
OCCURS.
THERE IS ANOTHER ASPECT OF THIS
THAT IS WAY BIGGER THAN RACE
ABOUT UNDOING SOCIETY.
JESSE, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE WAYS YOU
CAN PUNISH POLICE, THEY HAVE
UNION RULES.
THESE ARE POLICE UNIONS.
THE UNIONS HAVE DEVISED THE
SYSTEMS, SO A POLICE OFFICER CAN
HAVE 30 COMPLAINTS AGAINST THEM
IN A COUPLE OF YEARS, AND HE
GETS NO DISCIPLINE.
THAT’S ON SOMETHING THAT THE
UNIONS CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO.
AND ON THE POINT THAT YOU JUST
MADE ABOUT THEY CAN’T EXPEL
THESE CRIMINALS AND DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS FROM THIS MOVEMENT,
ONE WAY TO DO IT IS TAKE A
BREATHER ON THE PROTESTS.
THEY HAD A WEEK, IT HAS BEEN
HIJACKED, NOBODY IS TALKING
ABOUT GEORGE FLOYD ANYMORE,
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
RECKLESS VIOLENCE AND PROPERTY
DESTRUCTION.
IF YOU SIT DOWN, THE REST OF THE
LOOTERS AND THE CRIMINALS WON’T
HAVE YOU AS THE COVER TO
PERPETRATE CRIMES AGAINST THE
COUNTRY.
THAT IS JUST A SUGGESTION.
IN TERMS OF THE MEDIA, I HAVE
NEVER SEEN SO MANY PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS COMMIT SO MUCH
VIOLENCE.
HOW MANY EXCUSES DOES THE MEDIA
HAVE TO MAKE FOR THE USE ACTS OF
VIOLENCE!
THIS IS LIKE THE GUY WHO SAYS
OH, MY GIRLFRIEND ONLY CHEATS ON
ME WHEN SHE IS DRUNK.
AND HE SAYS THAT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
JUST BREAK UP WITH HER.
AND THE OTHER POINT IS THIS,
BILL de BLASIO, HE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS, JUAN
CONDEMNED IT, SO DID
BILL de BLASIO, HE RUNS THE
POLICE FORCE.
TO TELL THEM THE POLICE
CRACKDOWN AND THEN WE CAN HAVE
ENOUGH OF IT.
BECAUSE I WANT YOU TO BE IN A
BETTER MOOD, GREG.
>> Greg: IT’S HARD.
I WAS GOING TO ASK DAGAN IF SHE
WANTS TO BUY AN APARTMENT IN A
REALLY QUIET NEIGHBORHOOD?
>> Dagen: YOU ARE TRYING TO BE
FUNNY AND I LOVE YOU, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT, THERE IS NO TELLING
HOW MUCH THE PRICE OF THAT
APARTMENT IS GOING TO COLLAPSE
WITH WHAT HAS GONE ON IN TERMS
OF THE LOCK DOWN IN THE CITY.
HALF OF THE RESTAURANTS PROBABLY
WILL NEVER COME BACK IN THE
DESTRUCTION OF JOBS IN LEISURE,
HOSPITALITY, AND ALL OF THE
LOOTING THAT HAS GONE ON, YOU
WILL SEE UNEMPLOYMENT THAT COULD
BE UPWARD OF 30 PERCENT FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
BUT ONE REALLY QUICK THING IN
TERMS I WANTED TO MENTION,
GOVERNOR CUOMO CAN DO SOMETHING
RATHER THAN LAYING THE HAMMER
DOWN ON BILL de BLASIO AND THE
POLICE FORCE THAT IS CALL OUT
THE NATIONAL GUARD WITH THEIR
13,000, IN SAID HE LIKES TO TALK